- All right, well, this
is my favorite part
of the challenge, I
don't know about yours.
This is a football, or soccer ball,
depending on where you're watching this,
filled kind of all the way up with water,
so it's got a bit more weight to it.
I'm gonna throw it really
hard at the side of your head.
- Thanks, yeah, brilliant.
- I recon, expose the teeth and
I want to see eyes wide open
just so you can get the full
extent of skull movement,
Ready?
- Is it any good, that?
- Yeah, it's pretty good.
- [Gavin] It's like one of
those Newton's cradle things.
The ball just stops dead and
then your head carries on
at the same speed.
- [Daniel] That's ridiculous.
- [Gavin] Look at this, I recon,
this should be your Facebook profile.
- [Daniel] That'd be wicked.